[Laughter]
nation still talking about spider-man no
way home a lot of people are don't yell
at me this is something we want to check
out for the past couple days and then it
just dawned on me right now before we
hit record for the longest time people
being like you guys covered nothing but
cosmic wonder
spider-man no way home came on december
i don't think we covered a single
classic wonder video
what is wrong with us i almost forgot
what warren's voice sounded like so
sorry to everyone guys we have a brand
to uphold spider-man no way home
alternate post-credits scene let's see
what he has to say
[Music]
what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu i'm your host
warren thompson and spider-man no way
home is dominating the box office right
now it's about to be in the top 20
biggest movies of all time and that's
during a pandemic you have to wonder if
we weren't in a pandemic could spiderman
nelly home already have been in the top
20 top 10 maybe even the biggest movie
of all time already unfortunately we'll
never know but it's doing fantastic
re-release it's a talk today from people
over at marvel studios that supports the
fact that toby and andrew could be
getting some major screen time in some
upcoming marvel projects in fact they
could even go on to be in some projects
together again today we have some news
from the writers of spider-man knowing
home chris mckenna and eric sommers i
gotta meet them alternate spider-man
know a home post credit scene involving
tobey maguire and andrew garfield one
that we didn't get to see but almost did
and they also go on to talk about some
ideas and pitches they've had for toby
maguire and andrew garfield spider-man
down the road which is great news this
means that marvel studios is considering
keeping them around and not just using
them for this one-time cameo for both of
them in spider-man no way home of course
they're going to keep them around
hollywood's about money that's right
that's why they're restoring the snyder
version absolutely that cash cow is
finally coming home this movie made it
so much money during the pandemic easily
one of the biggest movies of all time
but nothing created more hype than the
possibility
of seeing these two all the three of
them together and now that it's happened
i'm pretty sure we're going to get them
for at least
one more appearance
yeah they have to they got to do it to
the point where we're like you've ruined
it yeah guys stop please
one spider-man that's it so in an
interview with variety spider-man no way
home writers chris mckenna and eric
summers revealed that there were other
plans for a different post-credit scene
involving toby maguire and andrew
garfield's lives in their own universes
interesting spider-man no way home we
heard a tiny bit about what happened to
andrew garfield and his universe after
the amazing spider-man 2 and tobin
maguire in his universe after spider-man
3. we heard a little bit more about
andrew's life than toby's andrew said
that at one point he got bitter he
stopped holding his punches he got angry
and it sounds like he got pretty violent
and i know a lot of people really wanted
to maybe see a glimpse into their lives
what has happened in their universes
after their last movies well to my
understanding tommy mcguire he
specifically requested that they don't
do any reveals about what happened after
to not get specific about anything like
that he didn't talk about why he didn't
want to do that some speculate that it
could be so that way it preserves him a
chance to maybe come back again and
explore it he's got an actual storyline
yeah he's got his own spider man
we still might get that down the road
and we almost got that in a post-credits
scene the writers revealed that there
were at one point in time plans to
continue toby maguire's and andrew
garfield story in the post-credits scene
for spider-man no way home now they say
continue the story so i'm assuming what
they were going to show us is toby going
back to his universe and andrew going
back to his and showing us what happened
during that time so this probably wasn't
going to be a look into the past and
what has happened since their last
movies but probably way too much their
universe is almost giving us a glimpse
of what could be coming for them as far
as storylines so for toby maguire
spider-man what we probably would have
seen is him going back to mj and perhaps
maybe even a daughter or some kids how
he's living does he live in a big house
does he still live in a small apartment
is there he's gambling
and then we have andrew garfield
spider-man and we don't really know
anything about what he could have
possibly been up to he just goes back
and starts beating up some wood
spider-man's a mess
yeah what can you say
i am a menace yeah that would have been
funny i don't know if i would have
wanted to actually have seen it the way
the the ending note goes it feels like
the possibility of putting a stamp on
this and giving us some closure that we
have been seeking for a while like it's
not everything we would have wanted
there's always going to be more
questions i like the idea that it ends
on the note it does it we don't see what
happens with them further leaving us
wanting us to see more
yeah and so then it doesn't become the
point that you should take away from
this movie is about them and or are they
going to continue i feel like it helps
things maintain that focus on tom hall
that's peter parker yeah but i still
want to hear what other possibilities
might have been we know that at one
point in time mj was supposed to come
into the scene she was even going to be
played by shailene woody and they
actually shot some scenes that never
made it into any cut but he did mention
to toby during the movie that he didn't
have a woman he didn't have any time but
my woman's conversation with toby could
have changed his mind about things
because toby told him not to give up he
told him that it was hard for him but
they made it work then not to mention he
saw how happy tom holland's peter parker
and zendaya were together and saw how
much they cared for each other so this
combined with what toby said could have
sparked a little bit of romantic
interest back into his mind about mj so
perhaps we could have seen him go back
to his universe and perhaps we could
have seen him get a different
perspective on life and spider-man i
love your pitch
[Laughter]
tom holland liked to you liked an mj
i know an mj
maybe i'll
but here's what the writers had to say
when teasing ideas that the team
discussed in regards to this movie
spider-man noway home chris mckenna
admitted that he would love to see their
stories continue saying i would hope so
i would love to see more of their
journey we even talked about oh we could
do a post credit tag with this one we
could do a tag with that one basically
stating that they talked about a lot of
ideas of what they could do with tobey
maguire and andrew garfield eric sommers
even joked around that they had this
idea of the two of them teaming up in
some type of tv show the two of them
going around in a van solving mysteries
together kind of like scooby doo he said
can we do a tv show with the two of them
traveling around in a van solving
mysteries this was an actual idea talked
about at marvel studios and sony and
mckenna added like no you weren't
supposed to say that we're doing a toby
and andrew in a van going from town to
town of course he was joking you'd be
doing this [ __ ] unable to say that but
the biggest thing to take away here is
that ideas for toby and andrew have been
discussed over at the studios there is a
good point to be uh have with this is
that the fact that they had so much
discussion about using toby maguire and
andrew garfield teasing the
continuations of their stories does like
credence to the possibility even more so
that they could be returning again for
some type of follow-up whatever fashion
that might be cameo supporting roles
stand alone who knows but the fact that
they were like we might be able to
continue it they should have done this
uh scooby-doo [ __ ] that would have been
such a great compliment to the let's
scooby-doo this [ __ ]
that would have been really fun and then
they absolutely like let's scooby-doo
and then they start going around like
actually spider-man scooby-doo
makes much sense about everybody well
that's the funny thing to me about
hearing all these is the more and more
and more ideas it seems like they were
batting around i almost feel like they
maybe didn't put either of them in any
of the post-credit scenes because like
some of these things are probably
likely to partially or maybe get close
to happening and i feel like those are
the things that then are decided by like
the business that surrounds how the
movie does and what word of mouth is
saying about which characters and so it
also feels like they probably have all
these ideas in a vault and are now going
okay what's the public conversation
because we're gonna greenlight a few of
these i also think they would all be way
too much to cram into like a 90-second
post-credits yes sure and i think
ultimately years down the road
everything kind of leads to avengers
secret wars battle world where we see
all of the variants of all of our
favorite heroes kind of come together in
a way and fight all the bad variants i
think the multiversal war is going to
happen again and i think all of the good
variants are going to have to get
together
cgi [ __ ]
doom galactus whoever is going to be
responsible for all the bad things
happening they'll have to get together
in order to defeat them and fix
everything but that's just my thought
let me know what you think about all of
this in the comments down below do i
even need to ask if everybody wants to
see toby and andrew again i think
everybody would love that but again let
me know your thoughts i'm personally all
for it and really really really hope it
happens i would of course love to see
them back again yeah especially andrew
garfield especially want to see that i
heard rumors about a spider-man 4
animated movie with toby mcguire i think
that'd be pretty neat if sam raimi
directed that i would love to see a sam
raymond directed animated movie holy
crap yeah yeah insane right yeah right
he's already got such an animation
flourish to a lot of it when he has full
creative reign
and so i would i would love to see what
he could do with that that would pretty
awesome because he does like storyboard
everything and he does he draws
everything out so i'm like might as well
oh dude yeah he would be the perfect guy
for something like that all right guys
well thanks more for putting this video
together subscribe to cosmic wonder
thank you so much for being here guys
and hey we'll catch you guys soon